logan webb will take the ball for the
giants and he doesn't have a win against
the dodgers yet he's all in one lifetime
but in the 10 innings he's faced the
giant the dodgers he's only allowed
three runs he's pitched well so
let's see what happens so it's second
and third and one out now bellinger a
six-game hitting streak stepping in and
he taps it to the right side that'll get
betsy
and
bang bang play at first good hustle down
the line by bellinger but he's out he
does get the rbi and the dodgers have a
one-nothing lead clayton kershaw is
coming off one of the best outings he's
had in years 19 swings and misses in his
last outing that was the most he's had
in almost three years so with clayton
kershaw going seven innings in his last
outing and the inning before in these
new rules for double headers only being
seven innings we could have a complete
game out of him today mike destromski is
a board
with a lead off single wing and a fly
ball
into deep center field it's going to be
a long run for bellinger and makes a
spectacular backhanded catch against the
wall
oh what a play by bellinger
robbing flores
of at least a double
certainly ostremski would have scored
from first and said bellinger with a
gold glove play in center field so two
down and here is darren ruff lines one
into left field long run and a diving
catch made in left field by
aj [ __ ] two spectacular defensive
plays by the dodgers in the bottom of
the first so two down here is rickard
the dodgers will bring the infield back
to normal depth
ball to third easy up for turner throws
to first the inning is over the giants
get a lead off double solano is less
crazy so that's a base runner handed to
the dodgers and now you got to face cody
ballinger he drives it to center field
going back onto strepski now he has to
pick up the pace reaches up and makes a
catch
he has got fooled a little bit there i
think by how hard that ball was hit and
how much carry it had and he ended up
making a very nice play to recover and
make the play
peterson who was hit by a pitch of his
first at-bat
is coming up dodgers one to nothing with
a chance to expand the lead here the
ground ball
to the left side of the infield throw to
first is not going to be in time
donovan solano having to go to the hole
throw across his body a short hop throw
to first peterson beat it in the score
is muncie now austin barnes coming up
and the dodgers have first and second
this one rope to left field that's down
the line and heading for the corner
taylor will come around third and score
on the run is peterson he's going to get
wave tall here's the relay from solano
not in time as austin barnes comes up
with a two-run double and the dodgers
now lead it four-nothing sweet piece of
hitting from austin barnes a couple of
sinking fastballs in on his hand a
fastball that he swung and missed that
and then a slider that ends up down the
middle mookie betts comes up for the
third time oh for one with a walk
grounded toward third diving longoria's
got it stands up throws the first in
time he got him what a play evan
longoria
wow
that was nolan aronado like
especially with the guy running mookie
betts in all his speed two down on the
play barnes went to third little check
swing roller
and this is gonna be a tough play for
longoria and sega does get him in and
excuse me base hit for corey seeger
barnes scores five-nothing dodgers right
now through the first three and a third
innings they're getting it done kershaw
is a five-nothing lead the defense has
been sparkling
here's donovan solano 1-1 solano with a
fly ball to right racing toward the
corner is benson he makes the catch now
he's draped over the side wall
another good play not just to get there
and make the catch but then the
concentration to hang on that's sitting
on
999 career basics ground ball in the
left field for a basic mookie bets with
his 1 000th career hit against a lefty
no less congratulations to mookie betts
who's going to grab himself a souvenir
down five runs and down to their final
three outs center field
yustromski back he's about to run out of
room he leaps
and
he makes the catch
that might be the first one of those in
this new configuration of the ballpark
where we've seen a home run robbery
because of the shorter wall
now pollock with a runner at third aj
pollock hammers one to left field
two on shot aj pollock his sixth of the
season dodgers lead it seven nothing he
dodged a strike away from going 23 and
9. kershaw going four and one
the one-two swung on and missed strike
three sabors retires the giants in order
dodgers shut out san francisco seven to
nothing in the first game of this double
header